Speaker 1: All right. Let's do one more.
Herschel Walker Badge Related Story.
This may be the funniest video I've
seen this entire campaign cycle.
In order to continue defending his having
a badge which is completely meaningless,
completely honorary confers absolutely no law
enforcement powers or abilities to Herschel
Walker of any kind whatsoever. He got a police
officer, I guess. And, you know, I have to say,
he got an obese police officer to say I gave
Hershel this badge because he's my friend. And
I tweeted about this and there were people online
who were saying, David, why is it relevant that
the guy's obese? You're fat shaming? Not at all.
Part of the absurdity of this entire thing is,
is this guy even really a police officer? And
part of it is in general, police officers at least
shouldn't be allowed to be morbidly obese. Okay.
It's not about fat shaming. It's about. Listen, we
understand you can't have a 55 year old morbidly
obese firefighter. It doesn't work or military
personnel or emergency medical technicians or
whatever. But do do we actually have 55 year old,
morbidly obese police officers? And if so,
why is that guy the one who is the one saying,
I gave Walker this badge? And it also makes it
less believable. This guy's even really a police
officer. Now, again, the guy doesn't have the sort
of, like, police belt. He doesn't have a firearm.
He's just wearing, like, a hat and a shirt. I
don't even know if this guy's really a police
officer. So that's the relevance of the obesity.
Okay. It's not about fat shaming. Here's Herschel
Walker and his friend says he gave him the badge.
Speaker 3: This is Herschel Walker. This is the
badge I flashed at the debate and this is my sure
Chevrolet. Yes. If Herschel's badge is a prop,
then I guess this badge I wear every day to
protect the citizen. I guess it's a prop also.
But these are real badges. And
I gave this to my friend for
a while. He's done for this country in this camp.
Speaker 1: Okay. So maybe. Maybe in this part of
Georgia, the sheriff. Dresses like this? I don't
know. I gave this to my friend. Isn't exactly.
Herschel Walker is in law enforcement. Every
single one of these moments that are meant to
prove that Herschel Walker is really sort of a
police officer only reinforce the reality that
he is not. And these are the sorts of moments
where, you know, I have family in different
parts of the world, Europe, Argentina, etc. and
I hear from them and they say, what the hell is
going on? What is it going on with this Herschel
Walker guy? I wouldn't want either of these guys
protecting me or my family. Every single step. The
story gets even more insane. And now the latest is
Herschel's. My friend and I gave him a badge.
Well, I guess he's a police officer then,
right? It's pathetic, folks. All these clips you
can find on our Instagram at David Pakman show